Before we discuss how to recovery from loads done
too early is happening, let's first talk about the
store to load forwarding problem. For a load, we
have to ask ourselves, which earlier store do we
get our value from? Basically, there could be multiple
stores to the same address that our load is
going to. And we have to figure our which
store is the one to supply our value and also,
if none of them are matching, then we need to figure
that out, because then we need to go to memory. When a
store is finally resolved, we need to ask ourselves, which later
load do I give my value to? So there might be a
load whose addresses already known, once this store figures out the
address and the value, we should be waking up the load that
wants that value. Note that there could be multiple loads that
the store needs to give the value to. So where do we
figure this out? In the load store queue.